I've played a lot of from software game
demos over the years and every demo is
better than the last but cicchitto is in
a different category entirely this game
is seven whole months away from release
and yet every input felt responsive
every death felt deserved except this
one and I swear I didn't fall below 60
frames per second a single time this
game has so much potential and I mean
you could see it in the faces of people
around me playing at Gamescom I watched
other people play when I got the chance
and almost without fail everyone did the
same thing at the start they see this
green don't slide into view and then
they use their grappling hook over and
over again just speeding between
rooftops and branches because you feel
it right away freedom you realize that
in all the souls games prior to this the
environments have controlled you they
restricted you they guided you but now
you control the environment
it's your weapon to use against your
enemies it's your safe space to retreat
and to heal it's always like a jump or
just a grapple away and it's yours in an
instant that sense of control is what
differentiates cicchitto in my opinion
from every souls like game before it and
that grappling hook is just one small
part of that control because what's even
more important is how responsive the
character feels take this scene for
example it's a good one think about all
the inputs I'm putting in here I managed
to jump off this ledge turn on a dime in
midair
lock-on and initiate a plunging attack
on the soldier below me my character
just responded to a ton of button inputs
and as I continued playing it felt like
the only thing really holding me back
were my own reflexes that sense of
control is what differentiates sukira
from every souls like game before it in
my opinion
another example is here when the
trol holds me off a cliff it was a
really embarrassing moment because I was
toying with him and just watching him
take burn damage but you see that green
marker if I had pressed l2 at this
moment I'm pretty sure I could have
grappled back up to the troll and man if
that had happened I would be showing you
an incredible clip instead of an
embarrassing one but I am getting ahead
of myself before I was thrown off this
cliff I had to kill a ton of human
enemies to get here so let's go over the
combat and how I fought my way to this
point
so first cicchitto has incredibly fast
to recovery times there's barely any
delay between attacking blocking and
dodging which when you think about it is
really different from souls because in
souls you're forced to commit to long
animations and long attacks but in
cicchitto your animation sequencing is
rapid and your reflexes take the center
stage this leads us to the posture
system in cicchitto you have no stamina
actually better way of saying that is
probably that you have infinite stamina
so this enables you and your enemies to
attack sprint block and roll to your
heart's content
but it comes at a price because instead
of stamina the resource you're managing
is called posture and at the bottom of
the screen now you can see my posture
and atop my enemy's heads you can see
their posture or if there are mini buffs
you can see it at the top in the middle
of the screen the goal is to completely
fill an enemy's posture bar which then
knocks them off balance and enables a
critical attack you can fill their bar
in two ways first you can test their
defenses by attacking them with our one
or you can parry their attacks
there is no parry button mind you you
just have to press the block button in
the instant they would have hit you the
better you time it the more they're
knocked off balance and the worst you
time it you won't take health damage but
you will take a big posture hit so
always remember the
same rules apply to your character
except when your posture is broken your
character gets knocked to the floor
instead of being critically attacked and
when you see this neon pink Japanese
character for danger pop up that means
the incoming attack can't be blocked
instead you can - or you can jump out of
the way
and yeah there's actually two separate
dodge buttons this time around so - is
your faster option it's what you're
already familiar with but sometimes you
actually need to jump over an enemies
attack instead now jump is much slower
but you can block and you can also
attack while you're jumping in the
middle of your jump which is amazing for
how fluid it makes the game feel you can
even jump off of enemies heads and
double jump on walls and all kinds of
crazy stuff so yeah you get the hang of
this pretty quick it took me about 15
minutes before I stopped floundering and
actually started playing well but as you
can probably tell this is far more
complex than any game that came before
it in my opinion I'm really curious to
see what the community thinks because
it's pretty unique to have to manage
your health and your posture and then
also on top of that manage whether
you're supposed to jump or - out of the
way when an enemy is attacking you
there's a lot of micromanagement in
cicchitto and it's fast-paced on top of
that so yeah mismanaging anything could
instantly lead to your death
but then one death doesn't matter that
much in cicchitto does it you see that
pink token in the bottom left above our
health that token represents
resurrection and pressing your right
bumper after death allows you to consume
it and come back to life now if you do
enough damage after your resurrection
you can actually earn this token back
which allows you to resurrect a second
time and if you do enough damage after
that you can resurrect a third time and
so on and so forth
I assume of all the systems from
software has repeatedly stated that
they're really tweaking the resurrection
mechanic to get it feeling right and I
have to wonder if there's a limit to how
many times you can resurrect I think
personally the max I got was three
before I died permanently so yeah I
guess shadows can die more than twice
and we've yet to see how many times
often you'll die in a position which
enables your stealth a Crouch which is
enabled when you press l3 so while
you're undetected you can of course
initiate a critical strike whenever you
see that glowing red lock-on icon and if
you're lucky enough to find some tall
grass you're pretty much completely
invisible as far as I can tell as long
as you don't enter the grass with a
weapon that's on fire because if you do
then it will set the whole field ablaze
and I did not expect that that's
something I can definitely see them
incorporating into like a boss fight
imagine hiding in the grass and then
having enemies trying to burn you out I
think that'd be awesome my flaming sword
speaking of which was enabled with a
prosthetic combo so prosthetic combos
are when you use your prosthetic trick
weapon and combo it with an r1 attack
with
Kitana and this is a mechanic that you
do not want to underestimate it's so
powerful so there were three prosthetic
weapons that you could use in this demo
there was the flame cannon the shrew
canal and the hand axe and prosthetic
attacks consumed white spirit emblems
which is a resource that you get from
enemies and it's displayed down there in
the bottom right as I mentioned you can
combo your prosthetics with r1 to
basically double their effectiveness the
flame cannon
for example combos to buff your sword
with fire the shrew can arm combo is
fantastic way better than I expected it
pegs a shuriken and then it closes the
gap with your katana in an instant and
the hair backs combo is basically an
instant kill on any smaller enemy it
obliterates their posture and enables a
critical attack and one touch that I
love is that enemies now jump back in
fear when they see you performing a
takedown on one of their allies and I
don't blame them because some of these
executions are brutal and guys I could
honestly talk about my experience hours
and I might honestly do that when I get
home I might stream this and talk about
all the footage in crazy high detail but
right now it's 3 a.m. in my hotel I
still have to edit all this together and
my microphone is failing me so I think
I've explained everything that needs
explaining and I kind of expect you'll
be able to puzzle out the rest from all
the footage I'll be providing and it's
hard for me to express this without
sounding generic but there is so much I
haven't talked about there are a couple
of incredible bosses that I'm not even
allowed to talk about and I wish I could
rave about every little detail about
this demo with you in person because
I've been lucky enough to have that
experience with a couple of guys here at
Gamescom and it's so much fun talking
about this game with other people who
enjoy it as much as you do if there are
any gaming conventions near you and the
next few months I would highly recommend
you check if secure oh is one of the
games that you can play there it
one of the most polished demos are
played in my life but before I go I
absolutely have to give special thanks
to Activision who made it well worth it
for me to fly halfway across the world
just to get some cicchitto footage and
talk about it with you guys thanks
especially to Joanna
Alexis Allison Tom and Priya they're the
reason this video exists and I'm hugely
thankful it's been a hell of an
experience I will have one more video on
sukira to work on when I get home I
think
but until then thank you so much for
watching check out the other sticky tour
video which is basically just all my
footage with all the raw music and
sounds and everything without me talking
over it in a tired voice but until next
time guys thanks for watching and I'll
see that